Going to your book a little bit. I'm
gonna, I'm going to, um, pick up.
Going back to that first thought.
Standing up means voluntarily excepting
the burden of being your nervous system
responds in an entirely different manner.
When you face the demands
of life voluntarily,
you respond to a challenge.
Instead of bracing for a catastrophe,
you see the gold,
the dragon hoards instead of shrinking
and terror from the all too real fact of
the dragon,
you step forward to take your place in
the dominance hierarchy and occupy your
territory. Manifesting your willingness
to defend, expand, and transform it.
To stand up straight with your
shoulders back is to accept the terrible
responsibility of life
with eyes wide open. Great.
The reason I pulled that
one out in particular is the
feeling that you have as a
soldier or as a,
as a military person,
a feeling that you have going on and
off offensive operation where let's say
you're a bad guy and I'm gonna come and
get you at night. Well, first of all,
you don't know and I'm sneaking up on
you and I have all this power, right?
I feel good about it,
I'm going to get you the opposite of
that is when I'm doing a convoy or I'm
going on a patrol where now
the bad guys are out there,
they're waiting to attack me.
And that is a defensive posture.
And your attitude about
that type of thing is bad.
Now we would train our guys that we,
we made a specific point with
my guys. I would say, look,
when you're on patrol, we're on
the offense, we are scanning,
we are looking to get the,
to get us to be standing up straight and
to get the mentality of we want to do
this and we're moving towards the
target as opposed to we're being chased.
That's a big deal.
Absolutely. That's a big deal. Yeah. And,
and that's, that's, what would you say?
That's an extreme example of what's
necessary under normal conditions in life.
So one of the things that happens if
you're treating someone who has a phobia,
say like agoraphobic. So they become
afraid of virtually everything. Um,
maybe they're afraid of an elevator.
It's one of many fears.
And so you think well,
and they're afraid of an elevator because
they've actually gone in elevators and
have panic attack.
So it's weird because what you do to cure
them is to get them to go in elevators
and you think, well wait a second.
That's actually what caused the problem.
So how can getting them to do that again,
make it better.
And the answer is because they've gone
in elevators their whole life, right?
And yet they still become terrified.
So how can getting them to go in an
elevator cure them for a long time?
People thought, well you get them to
relax while they were in the elevator.
And the pairing of the relaxation with
being in the elevator taught them to not
be afraid. That was the first
theory. But then people learned,
didn't know you could just get them to
go in the elevator without having them
relax.
And it also worked.
And eventually psychologists sorted this
out and what they figured out was that
voluntarily encountering something
you're afraid of is not the same thing as
running from it. Like it's seriously not
the same thing. So you say to the person,
you're afraid of the elevator,
let's can you go look at an elevator?
And they usually say yes and maybe they're
so terrified because they're so far
gone in their illness that they can't say,
well how about we look at a bunch of
pictures of elevators since like virtually
everyone can do that.
So let's say let's look at pictures
of elevators till your board.
That actually doesn't take very long
because it's actually quite boring.
So then the next thing would be,
well let's go.
You have to have the person trust
you. And so the rule is, look,
we're going to do some things that are
going to push you like competition,
but you can stop whenever you want and
we're not going to push you any farther
than is good for you and
all stop anytime you want.
I often practice with my clients,
like I taught one client a while back
to not be afraid of needles and he was
afraid of needles.
And I'll tell you what that meant.
He had dental surgery with no anesthesia.
Oh right,
okay. So that gives you some level
of what it's like to be afraid.
It's like all do the dental surgery, but
you're not putting that needle in there.
It's really,
it's like I'm no needles so,
so I taught them how to not be afraid
of, of needles, you know, and it,
it didn't take very long.
But the first thing I did,
I told him I was going to bring a
needle into the office. That was all,
I told him the first week is next week
I'm going to bring a needle in here and
I'm going to keep it sheets and it's
going to be sitting on a shelf and that's
where I'm going to put it.
And when you come in here,
you can look at it and if you want me
to put it away then I'll put it away.
It's under your control.
And then so he was okay with that.
So he came in and said
there's the needless, do you
want to look at it and said,
no, but Kenyon, it's like all look at it.
So he looked at it and then they said,
look like I'm going to pick up the needle
and now what you're gonna do is you're
going to tell me to put it down
and I'm going to put it down.
So I picked it up and he got nervous,
like right away, and he said, well,
you put that down. I put
it down right away. I said,
we do that 10 times so that the bottom
part of your nervous system actually
knows that that's what's going to happen.
Said now,
and then the next thing we'll do is
we're going to practice you saying you've
had enough and leaving the office. So
I'd pick up the needle and then he'd say,
okay, so now you say you've
had enough, I'm leaving.
And so he said that and
then I'd let him leave.
We did that like 10 times so that he knew
that he could just say he'd had enough
and leave. So that mean he didn't
have to be a prey animal. Right.
So we're getting them out of that mode
and it didn't take very long until,
well then I could bring the
needle close to him and I said,
make sure you watch it. You can't
pretend it's not there. Right.
I'll bring it close to him and touch
and touch them with the sheath needle.
So we did that a bunch and then finally
I unsheathed it and I'd bring it close
and he tolerate that or stop me
and then I'd touch them with that.
And then the last part of it was that,
um,
I put it under a piece of paper so he
couldn't see it and then I'd bring it
close to him. Right. Cause that
was, that was the unknown. Right.
You don't know what the hell is going
on underneath the piece of paper,
but he got to the point where he could
go and have a needle. It took them about,
it was very brave of him to do this
because, well, what had happened, he got,
what had happened to him is he had a
very bad experience with the childhood
dentist, held him down,
held him six people,
held them down to give him a needle.
It's like wasn't so good.
It had some long term consequences.
But see what happens. So when you,
when you do that with people,
you don't teach them to be less afraid.
You teach them to be braver.
That's different.
And so like I had a client once the
doors open on the elevator and she looked
and she said, that's death. Like
that's a tube. And I thought, wow,
that's an amazing response.
And her idea was she'd go in there,
her heart rate would accelerate,
she'd have a heart attack and she die.
So as far as she was concerned, walking
in, there was death. Right. Okay.
So for me it was an elevator, but for
her it was death. It's like, okay,
well what do you do about
your fear of death? Well,
we're not getting rid of that.
It's like, you know, and you could die
in the elevator. You actually could,
probably, you won't. But people do die in
elevators. And her idea was that, well,
if anyone has ever died in an
elevator in the history of mankind,
that's a good reason for me not to be
in the elevator. It's like, fair enough.
You know? And why aren't you terrified
out of your skull all the time?
Because while you're wondering around,
you might have a heart attack like that,
we'll probably in fact
happened to you at some point.
So why aren't you terrified of that at
every moment? Well, that's the mystery.
While,
so you treat people and,
and you see with that client
what I eventually did with hers,
we went and watched an embalming. She
was terrified of death. Like, seriously?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right. No
kidding. But you know, so you get,
you don't get less afraid.
You get braver.
That's better because there's
plenty of things to be afraid of.